[Music]
and Google to the rescue news submitted
by big spicy go choo yeah Korean go choo
yeah or are you someone sneezing
gotcha powder my goals you to a Google
search by a seventh grader got her math
teacher fired oh [ __ ]
what are the Sims creator of Google what
teacher look did he or she was it below
the name oh there we go
one two three uh alright so this takes
place in Miami and I thought you what
happened was the kid search they were
doing a science project and in there
searching for rock hard and it was a
dick I was wrong why would the teacher
get fired because the teacher was such a
full rock Clark maybe there's a maybe
there's a porn star named sedimentary
rock
oh and male porn star another feldspar
she felt she had a funny feeling about
her math teacher like honey I don't feel
like he would make her feel a little
uncomfortable that's great already
having those spider senses crazy math
teacher math yeah that makes sense if
you make math sexual you're predator
that's true math is very sexual y'all
mad used to make me horny as oh what did
you think what makes you learning mad
okay swear to God actually math was
sexual for me because my teacher mystic
Sarah was so [ __ ] hot that was the
teacher not mad though it's the text
blowing gun - she's right eight equals
equals D it didn't matter what she wrote
cuz I was like oh my god you didn't even
hear what he said though eight equals
equals D I don't know what that means
it's a ball set and if I was too busy
riding 8 0 0 8 5 on my cousin's thank
you that is all right so she it didn't
take her long to find a news news
article from 2007
detailing allegations against her math
teacher
Scott Scott - and so what it was was the
fact that back in the mid nineties he
allegedly taped a photo of a female
student inside a cabinet and collected
mementos from her including a lock of
hair and a tissue she had used to blot
lipstick and a duck dust control oh whoa
was he trying to clone her and he also
wrote inappropriate notes to other girls
and he told that he loved her there you
go I love you that's great so then
that's when he did not get his teaching
license taken away instead they just
transferred him to another school well
what are they gone on what is he gone
there there's points out of the Catholic
priests program yeah what the [ __ ] what
is he a private school teacher uh a
charter school is that private no it's
like semi charter school private [ __ ]
kids Mel Mel know how you get a horny
off of that [ __ ]
this is seventh grade kid oh yeah they
got that [ __ ] smell bad so annoying
well how many seventh graders do you
kick it with well when you're at a
[ __ ] church and you're a father
yester they walk around and if you don't
remember awkward stage - yeah their
limbs are all weird as [ __ ] yeah
ears are too big for the head and their
arms too long the body you know what
craters they [ __ ] look like they are
starving God dude dude I look what Jack
Skellington when I was in summer yeah
big [ __ ] head big hands like I look
exactly like how I do now no I was I was
511 511 when I was in sixth grade
holy [ __ ] so I only grew about two
inches after damn I was 6 4 in like
third grade gonna long I've been hauling
that everybody forever so you drive
yourself to school I don't know how to
do this yes then once the student found
all this information about her teacher
she posted it on snapchat and then by
the next time she went to school
everyone in the school was talking about
it yeah what a [ __ ] a few days ain't
the right thing it's old news for a
reason but what did he do at that school
did he did he pedophile at that school
too no I was just saying she got a funny
feeling about her look it up I love this
this is dough those those feelings are
true I've had funny feelings about
people woman's danger intuition is good
if there's no day just not real we
really told you this story but yes I
just had a funny feeling about this
guide I'm like Hello there's something
about that makes me uncomfortable so I
started putting passwords on my on my
computer and I just kind of kept an eye
on things and sure enough he was shady
dude my mom got the spider sense bud
like when I was when I was in my McDo
Joe doing Taekwondo there was a guy I
was a purple belt and take one and thank
you very much I still have the training
and then knowing all very well you have
to know I was I was like 7 years old or
some [ __ ] and and my my MA got a weird
feeling about this guy who was always in
class and who's like very friendly with
everybody oh and sure enough a couple
months later my mom's like go thumbing
through the newspaper and there is he
had just gotten busted for
[ __ ] a kid oh my god but then years
after that right I'm at a Pizza Hut and
this guy who had been like in our
neighborhood like a we were iOS rubber
bugs and bikes in my neighborhood with
my friends this guy like came into our
neighborhood and he would like race us
on his moped but he was like older than
us and he would like let us all win the
race and then like oh that's weird
yeah and then I saw him at the pool one
time too and he said hey to me and my
sister or some [ __ ]
and then I so then I'm at a Pizza Hut
for my dad's birthday and my mom like
I'm like oh hey mom mom my friends here
that guy like from the moped or whatever
and she looks over and her blood froze
she's like that's the [ __ ] guy in the
newspaper so my mom printed a bunch of
flyers you love this guy's face mom's
bad and she took the Flyers and put them
all over our whole neighborhood like of
like this guy did you know that this guy
has been in your neighborhood and all
[ __ ] and then it got on the national
news like my like wow great ABC News
came all these guys came they would
interview my mom like interviewing all
of us and [ __ ] was cool like yeah meet
him he wanted to read small page yeah
basically and then the ACLU tried to sue
my family yeah for putting his image
everywhere oh this is insane maybe I
don't know maybe but yeah they were
because he had served his time or
whatever the [ __ ] and my mom was here he
was still hanging out with kids which
violates his parole so [ __ ] that [ __ ]
right exactly
oh they did not win that no because when
you were walking around with your ass
out like the only time I was hot were
you wearing like snug basketball shorts
I was beautiful oh yeah yeah did you
peep into the brightest shorts not
supervised I was always out I could have
been easy as target and I always looked
up to like older guys and [ __ ] and you
know what that meant you were a busted
yo
do you want you would have never you
would have never gotten kidnapped
because you're too easy they have pride
as rapists dude yeah yeah you're too
easy do they like a challenge come on
now yes yeah maybe I'm just too aware to
but I always wanted like my teachers to
like take me after school to do things
and like like pay now like let's go
fishing or like whatever you know I have
some real cool teachers so in junior
high
um one of my teachers took all of my
friends to go fishing and I couldn't go
because it was on a Saturday and I had
to go to charters not that's not normal
it is no it was a private school oh so
it was like a Christian private school
so the relationship between and everyone
knew each other the students yeah and
then they all went deep-sea fishing
together and in like yeah parents would
go you know I will say Christian private
school sounds long yeah that's where all
the rapes happen right but I don't know
I don't care Christian has the the whole
rapey kid thing I think that's just a
Catholic thing oh maybe I just know it
was unfair I'd ever sin because in
Christianity you can still [ __ ] oh
really
yeah they're not that repressors [ __ ]
yeah ya know I'm always so
overprotective oh my exactly that's like
the biggest fear or anything like that
happening that's so sad I mean you just
never know I know but his teeth are
crazy so Mitch deviant he's fine it just
sucks that you can't trust people yeah
and then usually we see it's like people
that are close to you so I always ever
since he knows bro know I know ever
since I he could speak I would always
make sure it make it clear to him like
it's never okay for anyone to see you or
touch you unless I'm there and it's like
a doctor or like if it's like you know
you your dad if he's like helping you
shower or whatever but nothing too crazy
like I would forever make that clear for
him that's my mom did to me she's like
nobody can touch her PP Steven my mom
didn't tell me [ __ ] hey did my mom she
was like listen to older people and obey
them that's what she said Tim you were
the [ __ ] crazy
target oh my god and nothing ever
anybody could have had it no it's a
picture of young Joe and it says anybody
could have had it I [ __ ] jump into
cars to get rides to the [ __ ] liquor
store the park yeah what a grand Rite a
liquor store well they're not changers
they're like someone that was like you
know like I knew like this older guy
he's cool you don't even know their
names what were you going to liquor
store for my dad to get like candy stuff
yeah condoms superhead right he's like
oh I used to sell cigarettes but I just
made your like a bunch of like
pedophiles watching this and they're
like why can't they all just be like him
you know there's like older brother cool
guys that got cars and stuff or did
these pedophiles like oh I've always
heard of guys like that we're gonna you
know I feel like Joe had shorts with the
target on his butt they still wanted for
some reason thank God it get ad Oh God
anybody could have had I just had an
awesome childhood
[Music]
[Music]
you